all right so myself Lucy and tamal have
been dropped into an island in Eastern
Europe somewhere and we're going to
fight to the death
you were you keen for that guys I'm
citing a plane with a naked woman I am
when she's wearing underwear it's a good
starting this is a goddamn lay unknowns
battlegrounds top game it's probably the
best battle royal game out there at the
minute and Lucy Tam and I and this
random I'm gonna see if we can actually
survive it
Santa ger the guy from he's got an
incredible afro huh so I liked here uh
naked girls gone okay I'm finding a
place for us to drop I'm thinking I am
thinking don't really drop in the sea
yeah okay I'm gonna drop in three two
one out - all right so head directly
eastwards and hope that no one else is
fallen with us okay I can't oh I can
actually see a few players but they're
not going to be dropping too close to us
and try and land is close to the blue
marker as you can so to those of you who
haven't played what battlegrounds battle
royale game we're all in a team together
the objective is to be the last team
standing
we do that by killing everyone else
basically so we need to get these
buildings get some loot get geared and
then get to murdering get Wow killer
guys already killed a man with a
headshot punch
let's headshot punch sharp punch no
translators when opens grab these few
buildings and then we're gonna head
across the field oh there was another
squad the dropped to the southwest so
just be aware of that keep your head on
a swivel
keep cool don't freeze Oh buddy I'll end
it on a phenol myself and I landed on my
fence I smell like beef
okay I've got pistol
exactly n gameloop but it'll do in a
pinch you guys found a rifle but a
there's a rifle up here I think we got
out randos taking it no I'm looking at
it says pick up oh oh wait no let me
grab them is it over there I ain't got
nothing I got a gas mask oh and a
baseball cap that might bend em I was
looking at nauseous me I might have just
taken his ammo I don't know know I've
found the rifle
oh he's behind the door yeah I'm going
to this other little building all right
I haven't got a single weapon let me use
E okay we need to head west on my screen
to this circle that's the safe zone we
are nowhere near the safe zone and
there's a city between us sweet so we
need to move basically in the next 20
seconds so be ready we're gonna go up
and around the city all right never form
up on me you got 20 seconds yato
just having a nap I mean if Santa God
doesn't come with that Santa gets
problem yeah are you ready I'm here
that's my so I don't really want to go
through
yes nyah Pollyanna two more stand up
it's gonna be nothing squat so I'm gonna
see if we can go a little bit North
around it
don't risk me are we
Oh No have Oh who's knocked down Barry
chuckles 69 haha my tree that was
actually Barry chuckle just saw me home
playing play on our backgrounds I mean
what else you gonna be doing this time
um talking people with removals I mean
there is that getting into japes red
zone has started red zone is nowhere
near us safe zone probably couldn't be
further away the red zone is where all
the bombs fall it's a way to kind of get
players moving get out there's a spray
building up here I just need to be very
conscious at the time I've got to
balance the economy of having crap gear
and also having no time that's another
danger of kind of jumping at the plane
too early or too late is that it's
quieter it could be miles away there's
an ache a here if anyone who needs it
Moin tam you've already got an m16 why
you taking the AEK as well and Lucy's
got pistol and I've got Mike Rosie I
mean you should have a rifle join this a
okay
yes please tough I could need to hurry
I'm in the head there you go drop the
ammo
yeah I'm read there you go suppose feet
drop all the ammo tell me what to do
Tam I'll shoot you Massa T game I've
dropped it I don't have any more ammo
did you drop the right ammo how much
mone put it so you got Lucy uh ninety
okay we're good see giving us a lesson
using thank God for auto run my Lauren
isn't working my or run know like ever
just just hit equals
or the plus button it's the same button
yeah it wasn't much me you're lying
the aligns me good well manufactured fun
so we've got one minute twenty to run
very far
oh that is very fun all right everyone
look out for a car where I'm gonna run
us by a lake it's potential for a boat
there if we can get a boat that's just
as good
I've never seen a boat I don't even know
those boats in this yeah oh God I mean
they're quite rare obviously because you
know they're just just on the river or
the sea
oh well that town just getting
absolutely destroyed and I've never seen
anyone get killed by the red Sun no I
mean if we were a few feet to the left
it could've been us how could this
happen
right so what's that one armed with Lucy
you got a K I got an aka shotgun in a
pistol except I'm you've got um m416 yep
okay and a squeeze helmet I've got is
anyone got any meds
uh no I have painkillers and I'm one
energy drink I think I might have an
energy drink 69 alive nice nice oh that
was me thanks James
is that you that was me hey you're the
worst person's babies with yeah I've got
an itchy trigger finger
I asked Lucy Lucy's been first wanted
through the door next time I need to
clear a building the play areas get
restricted and we are still far away we
will make this Santa gate is just not
playing ball he's run off Santa God's
gonna die yeah not only is he running
into a city's dawdling when the safe
zone is going to come well rip buddy
check for a boat
hey Lucy hmm there's still 6969 alive
okay okay
um follow me follow me little bit in
Lord of the Rings when the seven muezzin
Dominic Monaghan gets a very brief
wealth Welsh accent I'm family Morahan
it goes follow me
okay let's animal have time to loot this
building quickly and like I mean you get
15 seconds in this building there's a
boat there yeah that's what we're going
for
I'll just meet you the boat I don't need
anything yeah Dave just grab the stuff
and we can have you got a backpack we
can just split your later now I haven't
got a black backpack you have so you
have not to go to back old little ravine
thing you go cover um crossing the gas
can in case hasn't got gas nice smoke
grenade
okay I've got backpack anything else I
need to come meet you I know where I'm
going so you guys jump in the back of
the boat I'll Drive I'm on my way
Oh felon get out the water how do I you
swimming that time no I'm behind you all
right lights I'm in the boat
I'm ready Swiney this is what I need I'm
coming captain's on his way up
Santa God is coming as well so we're
gonna wait for Santa God
hello two more Hussein we there is a lot
of activity I did you see a Jeep so be
ready here drive by and shoot at the
boat driver Jeep Santa get please oh no
Barry chuckles out I'm gonna drive us to
me right there naughty good
that's pretty center let's go boys
I need some like cool driving music need
like Vietnam War going down through the
river music basically black ops you know
fortunate is that mission from black ops
huh there on the Rolling Stones oh yeah
we can't do that we can't you can't
Aidid instantly and also expensive
Oh Santi guards put his own Santa guards
put a stupid marker up yeah that's not
good
nah nah me you're gonna have to jump out
completely ignoring Santa God
sighs guard like looked at you just
there as if to say do what the hell it's
in the middle of land and out the safe
zone watch out for the boat we're
professional captain I'm doing you
dressed up in your boat drift off deja
vu I lost about a bedroom oh this little
Dave fifth the boat drift trying the
safe zone I did on purpose I did on
purpose all right fine
because I did that on purpose because
the engine noise would have attracted
people okay pokerface star mp4 well
covered Dave huh well covered up exactly
thank you
and it's beach so no one else can use it
is complete that's look gunfire gunfire
okay got buildings oh I'm getting fired
up someone just missed me
I get Lucy just run yeah keep running oh
my god there's a guy here well there's
guys in this building there's guys in
this village okay okay okay I'm coming
behind are they I'm not sure nobody got
one earphone in this doesn't help me my
framerate just pooped the bed
oh sorry yawns Santiago I did I was name
is Santiago yeah got the parrot a parrot
y'all go in it and I don't all right if
you had a swivel guys there's still guys
around here hey Dave have you killed
someone or are you just kneeling really
really no I've made it a guy nice oh
Jesus Santiago don't scare me Lana
where's that guy scope go there is no
close close the door the door kept
opening all right
freaking me out all right what we're
doing we need to move inland I reckon we
go here and we are quick about it okay
roadie run or regular one regular run
whenever you're out in the open regular
run it's better to have speed whenever
like this cover or something or you're
trying to be sneaky there you're a lot
of gunfire in the fair mind but I shot
that guy he went down he didn't die yeah
so that means his friends are still
alive interesting we could hold up in
one of these buildings maybe and wait
for the storm to be over the middle ones
are quite big mmm
lot of space very bad sight lines though
we were on the top of the hill we need
to get our own room though yeah top of
the hill top of the hills good shout
King up that hill we will again see
quite quick old there's a hanger on the
right yeah careful there might be guys
in there yeah should we do we want a
chair we need to get in this building if
this guy's in there we'll have the
advantage
closed door behind you Oh son Tiago I'll
just paint ah he can show the door up
c'est bon floor area is weird look kids
it's quite difficult to get to the top
floor of this building you have to go
through a side door its various loot in
here I love various loot oh hello oh no
it's just backpack
I've got bandages I'm gonna take that
I've got any time scopes I'm going to
take the top floor back just I can just
be aware get your eyes get your eyes out
of a window there's gonna be there is
100% gonna be guys around here
all right I might take these stairs then
and watch a window we'll be able to hear
people coming closer yeah
so I am on like a window leg I'm on a
corner basically I can see stairs and I
can see window and what I'm on the rear
hanger I can hear someone it might be
Santiago so try and stay undercover and
usek the camera to see and try to move
as little as possible so it's that we
know if the movement is us or not I was
going to hang a gun hanger alright
where's the hanger what number the
directly east I'm gonna throw Grenada
there I don't know where that noise is
coming from these trees are blocking me
yeah the trees on my way there is a guy
in the hangar I was on the round side
where right hand side door told me give
me give me give me headings me headings
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Sun tea give me a
headache guess uh 105 seeing him he's
like ducking in and out of the hangar
area he's in the hangar area he's in the
hangar
okay throwing linear the right-hand side
door yeah I'll go him did you kill him
and knocked him out okay uh restricting
play area a fair way out we're still
we're still good was still good he's
still in the hangar his friend is gonna
be out trying to help him
I've almost I've run out of bullets on
my main gun Sarge then he popped out I
can hear some movement that adds me on
the roof okay if you're going healing
items Tam proper heal I don't okay um
just be careful I've got healing items
that I can give you I'm sorry for the
minute what should I come up oh [ __ ]
they're still in there hmm
they've got no reason to push us yet
yeah yeah they're gonna have a reason oh
man you got me that again the right now
he's leaving out hunt you
where you at town with that but if I
come from right right hand or the hanger
he's hiding behind those taking cover
he's still there yeah yeah okay well I
moved away to get healed shooting him
he's heading left that was one of them
his friend is still in the hangar
okay they might be trying to enter the
building
I can hear running yeah it's me on the
roof I might go downstairs and keep an
eye on the doors like a shot from
somewhere
ah they don't do downstairs dan says
that downstairs so he's running back I
think I went to close the door any
popped up against cover dan I think
they're staying there the hangar door
yeah I'm they're coming up and coming up
and coming up and behind ones dead ones
dead I'm dead
um this yoga I got you I'm knocked out
thank you I'm dead
sorry Tam sighs damn we're gonna have to
run straight away loose yeah just run um
yeah run nice run Wes don't lose don't
lose [ __ ] but here so don't lose don't
yell at me you're gonna get us killed
woman this way this way this way
you guys are go in the separate
directions get as a boat as a boat we're
gonna go off this boat you have you got
bandaged yeah bandage in our bandage now
bandage now how do I use it tab click on
it don't move
are you bandaging I don't know it's like
like right click right click on the
bandage there we go right there's a
first-aid kit on the floor grab that do
the same thing where II Hey got it okay
using pursuit get it don't move
no move all right [ __ ] sake actually
I've got time to loot that guy sorry oh
my god the zone turn blue and I thought
we were it was gonna be closing in on us
haha they've just wired all the loot for
himself I panicked I apologize damn
right
and take the m416 and the eight times
there's gonna be plenty of stuff if you
wait you I'm gonna come back up
ya can grab some loot if you need some
I'm going to take mostly em of five five
six rounds if you want to take actually
I am going to ditch my a K and take the
kr put the eight times on that four
times on this did you did you check to
make sure there's not another guy in the
hanger I don't think there is because um
the guy fell down and died in solitaire
died so I'll be them are you cool with
loot Lucy
yeah just cuz guys didn't have any like
health items which is no ideal oh I've
got a level two backpacks all right
let's go
alright we need to get the boat now yep
after you
so I'm now equipped with a sniper rifle
and an assault rifle nice the sniper
rifle is loud as hell but it means we
can engage at longer range and be a bit
more careful yeah by the way look a
baseball cap on fashion fast balls yes
Boop I like the simultaneous jump that
we might take a slither of damage all
right you win yeah yeah just take
another the vehicles are faster than the
saves on Hitler's own I think I've got
about two energy drinks so we can pop
one of those and toss up painkiller
bandage for take it oh I've got quite a
lot take your painkillers now top
yourself off you should be able to take
them on you're in the passenger seat for
boat but maybe not maybe that's just
bandages I'm sure you can do some
actions in boats
um okay oh my god the final area is in a
city Oh God
okay so what we're gonna do is arriving
get killed yeah basically actually we're
gonna take this hill okay once we get in
a safe zone
I'm trying to use the Rangers sniper
rifle to our advantage all right
I have no like idea of what the range is
mmm yeah but at that bridge
why have you boats on here oh dear
so I'm just thinking like I'm not sure
what once grow the map means hmm let's
get out
I've got him under the boat
me too no help me you good
uh yeah John what is this oh my god
just run it run it go up that man our
Lucy car huh come over here come over
here yeah okay there's an airdrop
happening next to you as well the ads
want me to go away
so you guys like oh they're itching out
I need it Wow yeah like in the middle of
walking under war my character keeps
like flee pose to pose to pose what we
talked about time I let you go hear what
I'm saying cuz he's on the other side of
the desks you keep doing t poses yeah I
keep going into t and she's like
freaking out maybe we should get up here
swim towards the end yeah you'll have a
gradual uh nice line there Yeager got it
got it gonna go to get a good got it
Jesus Dave they've just ran off I
thought you were right behind me no I
was doing the water I thought you got
out no that's why I kept saying she
keeps going into swimming alright let's
maybe try and hold up in one these
cranes I can't even get in here oh here
this game is very stressful it is is
high tension stuff can you get in the
plane in the plane I thought was a plane
behind you I fly away rain one tear away
I do see stuck in a maze yeah amazing
it's 36 alive okay that's a gunshot I
just heard do you know if that was that
you know it wasn't me where are you I'm
on top of the crane
hey hey come on now it's not the time to
have a fear of going upstairs huh oh my
god oh that's not not me this is
horrifying
yeah logo you do not want to be watching
someone climbing stairs in this game
there's a strikes trying to sail up here
keep our profile low oh my god I can't
even gets that great down down down down
left hand side from the water tower
which was out of there I don't know down
down down don't drown global I can't
move the camera so oh it's all there
below you next to that tree on your left
Lucy I thought I saw someone there cause
you that from you can see I'm here you
okay
I ain't seeing nobody nope how'd you see
movement by that tree I got you're in
the safe zone I am NOT oh no [ __ ] come
on Dave I mean I'm barely in the safe
zone okay I need to get down and get
across to you yeah
I'm still trying to figure out where
that shootings coming from when the safe
zone moves again though yeah luckily is
quite quick to get down here
um actually oh oh wow
I need help loose Oh coming Oh green
cake Green crepe up next to the green
crepe um down Oh God snuck up on me
another guy as well somewhere yeah oh
wow
head should number Taylor boys top to it
top ten that's not too bad all that
stressful confidence wedding oh well I'm
not gonna play again until I get home if
you enjoyed that video guys make sure
hit the like button subscribe for more
videos like this might try and play
small battlegrounds if that's the kind
of thing you guys like to see but I
think I need a breather and a lie-down
yes I'm a people got three kills between
us Gigi Gigi goes to work
Gigi
you